assalamo everyone hopefully better
phaser broken system defense hope you
guys are doing well welcome to this
video this video is something I'm really
wanting to do the reason wanted to do is
not because I enjoy it in a way to see
such horrific things happening rather
than made well it may come from and well
may be doing it but the sad reality that
when it's a Muslim who is doing the same
act when it's a so composite or into the
same act which was done in Westminster
about maybe a month ago etc obviously
those outrage etc Islam was to blame
Islam possibly and this was an
individual who was a Muslim but it uses
an alcohol be involved in drop etc
especially with a sinful Muslim yes it
was a person we can't really say he was
practicing his religion properly right
however besides the point his religion
was blamed as usual his religion is
blamed
yeah but why is it why is it that
similar acts you got similar act clear
one of them is supposedly we don't even
know even shouted or not or whatever
here one of them is just saying Allah
was well and doing that however the
other address for example in America if
we think with there's a mass shooting
not shooting why don't we ever come and
see you know what Caucasian looks so it
is young Caucasian men you know why are
we go to young female men and go to like
Tony Robbins and then caused him to
condemn it no because it won't be right
with it no it wouldn't however in this
instance is an individual who is running
over in a city yet in a city running
over so many people coming out and
shouting and screaming and what's the
common factor he was taking drugs also
the only difference is where the
resonances happened this guy is that
they're both were involved in drugs and
they party lies which is very similar
maybe to tal Robinson's lifestyle more
than a Muslims but one is the shouting
maybe in the name of the son the other
one isn't and you blame the other person
because he shouts a certain phrase but
because the other one doesn't is
not terrorism terrorism is causing
terror in public to innocent people how
can you define that anyways anyways I
wear them around let's watch for
ourselves and see the severity inshallah
left inshallah
some are mistaken there's a CCTV footage
okay and that's there's there the no
suspected vehicle
okay so so this is the individual
there's not sound to it by the way
what
Oh
an absolute maniac but you have to be
Wow wow man
[Music]
you
then he runs over people what's he doing
government
now brothers and dear friends if you
guys are watching this what is the
difference between this guy and any
other terrorism app now you can come a
season oh but in your scripture it said
go and kill the infidels whatever for
example yeah okay all right
phrase aren't we yeah even though it has
no such no such thing and that's what
this challenge once again and I'm always
putting it out there for Tommy love
isn't written verse all the fashion
races individuals I will give you a
thousand pound cash cash show me a
single verse from the Orlan from the
Prophet Naima his lifestyle with Hadees
anywhere that commands asked Muslims to
go out and kill innocent men women
children babies animals it's absolutely
forbidden absolutely forbidden both are
mania you have something in common you
are a maniac the other person is also a
maniac but he is a maniac which goes
under the name of Muslim the other
maniac
Anders Breivik who was in Norway condoms
came with a mass shooting was a maniac
who in the name of Christianity then in
unabated sack Stalin who killed millions
fifty million people you have Mao Zedong
who's a communist 15 70 million people a
mother mania you have Hitler another
maniac who hated the Jews etc etc you
have different kind of mania so for
example the guy from Britain first there
is one of the members who kill the the
ladies from the Parliament there John
Cox if I'm not mistaken
another maniac they all have something
in common they are maniacs this is
something in common you can see the
three US and the British public are
cosmos have a British are Muslim I'm
almost in Britain Britain British as
well
we as general public we have something
in common right because we are against
violence against innocent people
innocent people if it's in this country
if it's an Iraq where one minute we were
killed by America in Afghanistan
wherever it may be terrorism is
terrorism there is no religion for
terrorism terrorism is terrorism killing
innocent people is terrorism so that's
why brothers and sisters and the effect
if you're watching this is well I want
you guys to know the differentiation
between us in the British public and
briefer and email and Isis and Hitler
and Mao Zedong all these individuals fit
into that category
you know however the basic distinction
these groups all feed off each other
Isis on Britain first and Evo people
feed off each other they both have a
common understanding the ISIS s Islamic
terrorism Britain first any deal and
from Rosa is sama terrorism they have
something in common but the general
public as we know I know my religion
doesn't teach that you guys know my
religion doesn't teach that that's why
you don't blame me because if everyone
would be guys like Tony Robinson this
will be a really bad country to visit to
be honest and like I said before brother
and sisters Allah says Alice want I said
in the Quran if you cure one salty
Pacific you the whole of humanity if you
say once all this since as you say the
whole of humanity the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him and when he had treaty
with the Jews and the Christians he gave
them their rights you have a right to
worship they lived in harmony together
they lived in harmony together you can
check research they lived in harmony
together he gives them the right he said
if anybody haunts a non-believer than me
yes he's under the protection of the
Muslims he would not smell the faces of
Jenna
when the smell goes the flavors of
gelatinous melting this much distance
away so guys let's counteract this and
share through the anonymous infants
because this is a non-muslim you have
become you've barely heard it around and
even if you have guess what we've heard
drunk maniac loner that ah that ah well
it's a Muslim when it's a Muslim is this
guy I bet you is the media so this guy
just walking past the mosque I guess
that's when he walked part of the mosque
he said yes I must do something he was
influenced by that so guys please please
please share to your friends and family
and your numbers and friends let the
people in the world see the hypocrisy of
the media the double standard and we are
usually platform use that to the best of
our ability so brothers and sisters
share this and
let me know and said mrs. Marin sir and
skin this is honourable Robinson and
asked them to condemn this app because
this man has got more in common with
them whether it's drug abuse and alcohol
and their party lifestyle it's a more
common with them so they should I wanted
to culture apologize we want an apology
guys thank you washing ceremony cool
what I'm already been careful